very good like this we steal that here
I'm doing on our pocket oh really you
know excuse me
how about if you do this you can go oh
whisper out so-and-so credit Johnny
Sanchez if you do that yes it Carlos not
that for you when he stole your jokes
dude I don't [ __ ] steal I borrow
without [ __ ] asking anyway so I knock
him dead or I'm sorry Ned
it's like cuz I think if you listen so
it's gonna break his heart no he knows
where I love you we love you we're just
now right we love you so [ __ ] I'm
gonna get that all started he won't get
all I know but he's he he's done some
stuff to you alright do you remember
when yes I say it I already know you can
I say it funny is funny
yeah we did funny is funny wait I didn't
finish that just note it down yeah just
note it down this is how this thing
works
I know I forget I know you do I know
it's great because you know growing on
the farm land you probably had it's like
fertilizer poisoning or something you
know well I did grow up in that area I
know you did but I got some news for you
about all that okay
alright you're gonna have a change of
jokes about money by the way later
let me just rip rip ribbon and save it
yeah okay so over I was lost my train of
thought
Carla oh yeah so funny it's funny what
did he do so we were given our that was
crazy we give our sets yeah we give our
sets and so everybody know when you're
when you're okay so everyone everybody
knows everybody's material yeah but
everyone you're listening when you do a
TV show correct it tonight or whatever
it might be right for months and months
you have to date you write down your set
word for word because it has to be you
know you know the network has to approve
okay correct so um we all know
everyone's bit it's also on teleprompter
which why would a comic forget but
they'd still put it on at all
bullet points to put your bullet point
right like each topic like you know like
you know his would be like pulling pants
down finding things like that
mine would be like in-depth but his
would just be that's what you basically
have screams screams again pumps to
listen the man when he's down I'm so go
kick a man when he's down down okay by
the way I never forget Pablo Francisco
but I don't know how much how much room
do I have on this I remember years ago
papa goes he would be on stage and
anytime there was like a weird moment in
his set yeah he would I would notice
he would always he would always go I can
take the foot I can take the headphones
off he would always go like this he'd
always go yeah and then the audience
would start cracking up or whatever and
then even later on later we'd be working
I go that's funny so he goes he's all
yeah buddy whenever I hit a weird thing
goes everybody loves humping wow this
works every time ping pong this is why
we have a modeller notes take notes
yeah just hump the stool or just hump
the yeah yeah up-and-coming comics so
you're doing funny fun we're all doing
funny it's a TV show on Telemundo CTV
CTV my part it yeah my bad yep CTV right
Nazi but yes si right so and Carlos is
hosting note I want to say some of this
stuff oh I didn't know that okay just we
just talk freely and then if you don't
like something yeah there's my
girlfriend Kalani
oh he just ran in here oh that's rare
what is that what do you do he he I put
my hand down and then he went and just
turned yeah you know cuz he gets it yeah
you he gets it
that's how that should have ended he
works fries okay so so everybody you
know they get all of our material sure
not only the bullet points but they know
exactly what you're talking about for
that seven-minute set yeah everybody's
doing like seven yeah and their little
pet store can I tell a little backstory
though I think it helps oh yeah I'm
missing you're missing something that
maybe I okay Steve
okay right that you haven't perceived um
is is that for years
heat net had asked you to open for him
correct every time you say absolutely no
correct oh and I think all the years of
you saying no it hit him a little bit
because you know I did it Brad Williams
Freddy did it you're coy yeah delete I
move all done I've done it the most but
we still did things you said know every
time every time right but I actually
said it early on when before any of her
any type of reputation of a came it was
something when I used to watch him and
maybe I was just not thinking right
because I was young and I was but I was
like that's his path is this way and my
path is this way and I felt like his his
guys were like you and Jo koy and even
Freddy a little bit Freddy was
definitely on the ethnic side of the
Mexican material right okay right you
and Joe you guys are and delete guys
like you aren't even in his Lane he
doesn't even in near his Lane or
anything like that
right yeah now I'm on the complete
opposite and I felt like his audience
yeah would not even care for my [ __ ] ah
it was more now later on of course it
was it was more of the reputation and
hearing things and hearing the the hell
gigs on the for the guys that are
opening for him is what I used to hear
later but at first it was just my choice
I just kind of went I told him that he's
like Duke come on the [ __ ] road with
me what are you [ __ ] dude oh [ __ ]
help you you know I was like and I told
him
yeah I said dude I go I go I just think
we got different audiences man yeah I
mean that's not and not that I'm saying
I just wasn't I had I had horses winders
yeah that I had the blinders on do it at
that point yeah I knew exactly direction
like the horse RAC donkey very good not
that in I got in there right yeah pretty
good on everyone laugh at it he didn't
give you anything I know he's my enemy
uh he's my enemy for sure so so in a
weird way Bobby yeah I kind of had this
vision already even though in hindsight
you know other got guys like Johnny's
app or telling me you should go on the
room you're gonna get a bigger audience
but I don't even think you win so say
Johnny's app in this maybe that's for
the rest of named Johnny's down after
now right no one knows Johnny's a
pannier I [ __ ] he still pops around
the store I know all right so this guy
named Johnny zap who you know if you go
to a common club any comedy club I've
been all over all right there's always
somebody that's a regular that's not a
stand-up yeah but that's been going to
this club and hanging out for hang out
for 30 years
right that's what Johnny's happened so
he's this older guy and in the audience
he used to just because he'd been there
for so long do the dance
yeah right and then you're on stage and
you're like dance right and sometimes we
wouldn't know it was him yeah is he
trying to change his voice a little bit
and then and then we'd hear he would do
the laugh so that and then do the laugh
so that we knew that he approved of our
joke or new joke yeah he also looks like
kind of the human version of Papa Smurf
I arrived with a Brian Johnson Hannah
yeah what is that too old of a reference
yeah but where's that paper boy the
paper the paper boy hat yeah no no uh-uh
I know you love them it's no it's Bon
Scott first and then Brian oh hey do not
did I do a poll right now [ __ ] all
right now listen
so now cut to where at funny is funny
yeah I've got it right and and also I
want to say is this we've we never never
talked negatively about Carlos the
reason why is because I do love him yeah
you had a great relationship with he's
done so many good things for me
you know but those I've been thinking
about where did where I can go where I
can't go do you think he would you
properly 100 percent ask him all the
things you want to ask him that's why he
I can never have them know because if I
have him I wouldn't be able to ask him
the questions that I really do want to
ask because I don't want to hurt him I
feel like he's hurt enough and I don't
want to kick a man you know when he's I
think he's down he's making a living
he's doing stand-up but we know where he
was
[Music]